en el vídeo sobre la segunda ley de la
termodinámica hablo de cómo la entropía
del universo está en constante aumento y
que no va a disminuir y otra forma de
pensar al respecto es que cada vez más y
más energía en el universo va hacia la
entropía se está volviendo cada vez
menos útil y el argumento que utilizo es
que en nuestro día a día mientras estoy
haciendo este vídeo
mi cuerpo está generando calor y ese
calor conduce a la entropía genera más
entropía en el universo y una pregunta
razonable es cómo puede el calor
conducir o llevar a la entropía recuerda
el calor es una transferencia de energía
térmica y la entropía es un estado del
sistema es la cantidad de desorden que
tiene el sistema es el número de estados
que un sistema puede asumir veamos un
ejemplo aquí vamos a suponer que se
trata de un sistema ideal cerrado este
pequeño cuadrado blanco de aquí y estas
moléculas están rebotando a alguna
temperatura por lo que tienen una
energía cinética promedio
y cada molécula va a ser cosas
diferentes y siempre lo dibujo como esta
energía cinética de traslación pero
podrían estar rotando y oscilando y
haciendo todo tipo de cosas podrían
estar haciendo otras cosas también pero
la energía cinética de traslación es un
poco más fácil de visualizar ahora vamos
a aplicar algo de calor al sistema así
que tenemos una transferencia de energía
térmica lo que llamamos calor y usamos
la letra q para denotar calor así que
tenemos una transferencia de calor hacia
el sistema y luego debido a esto la
temperatura del sistema sube la energía
cinética promedio aumenta y estas
partículas empiezan a rebotar con más
momento con más velocidad así que porque
este sistema tiene entropía podrías
decir bueno tiene el mismo número de
moléculas en el mismo volumen aunque la
imagen está en dos dimensiones y podría
parecer más bien un área pero podríamos
imaginar que estamos hablando del mismo
volumen que se está llenando y se siente
como si hubiera el mismo
número de lugares en donde las moléculas
podrían estar pero nuestro estado no
está determinado exclusivamente por la
posición o por el lugar donde se
encuentran las diferentes partículas el
estado es todo acerca del sistema que
podamos utilizar para predecir lo que le
va a pasar después al sistema por lo que
el estado también incluye las diversas
velocidades de estas partículas así que
cuando tiene una temperatura más alta
hay un mayor número de velocidades que
podría tener y también cuando tiene esta
alta energía cinética recuerda que todas
estas moléculas están formadas por
átomos que tienen núcleos y que tienen
electrones girando a su alrededor y si
no tienen suficiente energía cinética
podrían no ser capaces de acercarse así
que digamos que estos son los electrones
externos de un átomo
y digamos que aquí hay otro y tienen una
energía cinética razonable y con esa
energía cinética van a poder acercarse
solo un poco pero si estuvieran
moviéndose más rápido podrían ser
capaces de acercarse más podrían incluso
deformarse un poco entre sí imaginad dos
bolas que se golpean entre sí a gran
velocidad se van a empujar una a la otra
con mucha fuerza por lo que hay más
estados posibles que se pueden asumir
cuando se tiene mayor energía cinética
así que estas se golpearon muy rápido y
se le formaron una a la otra mientras
que estas fueron amables y educadas y se
acercaron a una velocidad gentil
así que se podría incluso tener más
estados posicional es más
configuraciones diferentes en el espacio
tridimensional y es por eso que el calor
conduce a la entropía solo que algunos
de ustedes podrían estar diciendo el
calor no sólo causa desorden de hecho el
calor puede ser utilizado para hacer
trabajo y de hecho esa es la base de la
revolución industrial las máquinas de
vapor y los motores de combustión el
motor de combustión en tu coche que
utiliza el calor utiliza una reacción de
combustión para empujar un pistón lo
cual se utiliza para hacer trabajo y eso
es por supuesto cierto y tenemos aquí un
ejemplo de ello tengo algunas moléculas
aquí moviéndose por todos lados a una
cierta temperatura y luego voy a aplicar
calor al sistema así que vamos a añadir
calor al sistema y en este sistema no
tengo solo un contorno cerrado estas
moléculas empiezan a moverse más
pudiendo asumir más estados y pueden
utilizar ese movimiento para expandir el
contenedor lo que vemos qué sucede aquí
empujan este pistón y así están
realizando trabajo y cómo se está
haciendo este trabajo bueno mientras
estas moléculas están rebotando por
todos lados estamos hablando de una gran
cantidad de moléculas de vez en cuando
algunas de estas moléculas van a chocar
aquí y luego rebotar
y eso va a dar un poco de fuerza por una
cantidad de tiempo muy pequeña lo que va
a empujar esto hacia arriba un poco pero
hay tantas moléculas solo dibujen unas
cuantas pero en cualquier sistema
termodinámica real vamos a estar
hablando de muchos millones y millones y
millones
estamos hablando de múltiplos del número
de avogadro de moléculas y así en un
momento dado muchas de ellas van a estar
rebotando contra el pistón y van a estar
haciendo el trabajo van a estar
desplazando este pistón con un
componente de su fuerza van a estar
empujando este pistón hacia arriba y
haciendo el trabajo pero no existe un
sistema o motor que funcione a base de
calor que sea 100% eficiente así que
algo de esto puede ser utilizado para
hacer el trabajo pero mucho de ello va a
añadirse al desorden del sistema para
aumentar el número de estados que el
sistema puede asumir una forma de pensar
en ello y esto siempre me ha ayudado es
que el calor es la transferencia de
energía térmica
y eso ocurre en el límite del sistema
este calor podría ser una flama aquí
abajo y si esto no fuera un sistema
completamente cerrado podría liberar
calor en los límites del sistema pero
dentro del sistema el calor el
incremento en la energía térmica está
conduciendo a un aumento en la entropía
ahora bien también hay trabajo en el
límite del sistema aquí arriba
probablemente hay algo de calor que es
liberado pero también es capaz de hacer
trabajo así que el calor y el trabajo se
están produciendo en los límites del
sistema pero una gran cantidad de esa
energía va hacia el interior del sistema
y eso provoca que las moléculas choquen
entre ellas mucho más rápido y generar
más estados que podrían asumir y es por
eso que cuando hablo de que si estoy
caminando la fricción con la alfombra va
a generar calor y eso va a contribuir a
la entropía en el universo el simple
hecho de que exista los procesos
celulares en mi cuerpo que generan calor
aumentan la entropía del universo
que hace que la energía total del
universo sea menos útil